the 27 heads of state and government
had an in-depth exchange on our
relationship with China and we have a
clear position, all member states
are united on this point and this summit
was prepared by numerous
high-level dialogues on  the economy and
trade the climate and the environment
digital human rights among
other subjects and today we have
continued to build on the basis of the
work already started and we have the
European Union and China interest in
maintaining a stable relationship which  must
be based on respect for
international law based on the rules we
have discussed our
economic and commercial relationship the
European Union and China are major
economic partners of great
economic powers we exchange
some 2 billion in goods every
day that being said  the European Union
has a trade deficit of almost
400 billion euros and this is why
this economic
and commercial relationship must become more
balanced the European Union continues
to work for fair conditions of
competition for our
companies and expects  China
to take more
concrete steps to improve
market access and the
investment environment for
foreign companies. We intend to
continue to diversify our
supply chains and review our
dependencies to  to be able to
deal with the problems that arise in the future,
for example graphite,
graphite is completely fundamental
for the defense industry, but
China has decided to limit its
exports of graffiti and this has
consequences for sovereignty and
the strategic autonomy of the
European Union here is an example which
clearly illustrates what is at work the
European Union must better propose its
interests and this does not mean that
we want to decouple ourselves but that we
want to have a look turned towards
inside no we consider that
we must have a
multilateral system with the WTO at its center
ladies and gentlemen at this very moment
Russia's illegal aggression against
Ukraine continues and you know
we are firmly on the side of
Ukrainian people we consider that this people
has its future within the
European family as a permanent member
of the Security Council of the
United Nations China has a
particular role to play since this war
threatens global stability the
world economy and that  'it also has an
impact on the most vulnerable around
the world since because of this war
we have greater
food insecurity with higher prices
for raw materials this is not
in the interest of the  European Union
it is not in the interest of China
it is not in the interest of the world and
this is why we
invite China to show
a constructive spirit on this issue
because the  China continues to provide
access to technologies that are
likely to be militarized, but we
want these goods to no longer be
exported to Russia
and we therefore ask China to
help us fight against the
evasion of sanctions. Moreover,
we have also  mentioned a
tragic war taking place in the Middle East
and from the very beginning the
European Union condemned the horrible attack
committed by Hamas against Israel
Israel has the right to defend itself
in accordance with international humanitarian law,
including the principle
of proportionality  every civilian life
counts all necessary efforts
must be made to protect
civilians the humanitarian situation in Gaza
is catastrophic and we are the
European Union the main
donor of aid to the Palestinians we
have multiplied this aid by 4 to
reach 100  million euros with
China we agreed that the most
vulnerable must be able to receive
the necessary help it is a priority and
we decided to relaunch the
political process on the basis of a
two-state solution peace
stability matters  anywhere in the
world including here in Asia and we
are concerned about the growing tensions
in the Taiwan Strait and the
South China Sea we oppose any
attempt to change the status quo by
force or coer
l  The European Union maintains its
One China policy. China,
I am sure, is fully
aware of the repercussions that
an escalation in the region would have for the
European Union. Human rights and
fundamental freedoms are
rights and freedoms.  universal and
we will never be able to look away from the
violation of human rights
today we are resuming a dialogue
on human rights with China
this was the agreement we reached
during my previous visit this is a
step in a  not in the right
direction and we will continue this
high-level dialogue we have
notably mentioned the more
specific issues of the
Ycheng Human Rights Defender and Tibet ladies and
gentlemen the only way to deal
with the difficulties we
face and to work and  cooperate
together and we therefore highlighted
all the areas in which we
should work together we
asked China to be more
ambitious to fight
climate change and protect
the environment we also
asked China to join
global commitments  to triple the share
of renewables and double
energy efficiency by 2030
but also to reduce
methane emissions we
also want to improve the
global health situation this must go through
a new treaty on
pandemics China must  assume its role
and in particular finance the effort that will be
necessary in this regard with Madam
President of the Commission we are
here to promote the values ​​of
the European Union to protect our
principles we have progressed in
areas which are of common interest we
we will continue the dialogue with
China on other issues such
as
reciprocity now we must move
faster we must transform our
relationship so that it is fairer
that it is more reciprocal and
that together we are able
to  facing the most pressing issues
thank you Madam President of the
Commission Ursela V
derlen thank you hello everyone today
this summit was the occasion of my second
visit to China this year and this
clearly shows the importance of the relationship
between  European Union and China
we have a complex relationship with
China a relationship which requires
frank and open discussions to
better understand each other this is
exactly what happened
today it was the choice  from this
summit we had the opportunity
to explain our concerns and
concerns to the Chinese leaders and
also to move forward in
key areas of our bilateral relationship I
would like to start with the economy through
trade and investment and
well we  we really need to
rebalance our relationship as
the President shared with us his
vision of things on the
Chinese economy we exchange
2.3 billion worth of goods every day and this
clearly shows that the economic relationship
and the exchange that we have  with
China is fundamental that being said
we consider that this exchange is
particularly unbalanced the
trade deficit amounts to almost
400 billion Ur and this deficit was only
40 billion 10 years ago this
therefore means that it  there has been a
considerable increase this deficit has only
widened in fact it has doubled over
the last two years and this is for
many Europeans a source
of concern and such an imbalance is
not all  simply not
sustainable, we know the
underlying reasons and we have discussed it, on the one
hand,
the lack of access to the Chinese market for
European companies, then the
preferential treatment of
Chinese companies and finally the excess
production capacity on the Chinese side, these
production surpluses  then are transported and
sold on world markets and we
see this A D ago and already different
regions which are in the process of closing themselves
to Chinese products which means that
even greater surplus capacities
seek to be sold in
Europe but we do not  we cannot accept
that our industrial base is
damaged by unfair competition competition
we strongly appreciate it
because it makes us better it
lowers prices it is good for
consumers but competition must
be fair we insist on
conditions  fair competition
within the internal market and
consequently we do the same uh and
we impose this same constraint on
foreign companies which come to
operate with us I am happy uh
that we have agreed with
President Chi on the fact that
trade between  we have to be
balanced it is obvious that we have
also addressed the issue of
risk reduction which is not a
decoupling China has for a long time
adopted a similar approach the
Chinese called it their work
of self-sufficiency and it has been  done within
the framework of a regulatory approach
essentially I want to say things
very clearly here Europe does
not wish to decouple its economy from that of
China uh we had for very
good reasons to decouple
the Russian economy we  we do not want
to have to do it for the Chinese economy
so what does this reduction of risks
consist of and well uh
to analyze excessive dependencies
in order to div ify our sources
of supply so that
it is  more robust more
resilient that we can
source from several
suppliers this obviously
strengthens our resilience and this
is not just about
China we must also learn the
double lesson of the
covid-19 pandemic  and the outbreak of
war started by Russia against
Ukraine and at that time we
saw it we saw it when we have a
single supplier and that supplier
decides to stop supplying
d  'supply well that is very
painful that is why
we have the duty to diversify our
supply chains we
also discussed digital in
general and
artificial intelligence more precisely for
us there is  obviously great
opportunities but also great risks
with artificial intelligence and the
whole difficulty consists in guaranteeing
both security and innovation
on our side the market forces will
not achieve this
alone it is obviously good  to have voluntary
safeguards and safeguards
but at
some point we will have to have binding rules
we have on the Chinese side a
global governance initiative for
artificial intelligence the
European Union is in the process of putting the
finishing touches  to its own legislation in
this area in order to ensure that
artificial intelligence is consistent
with our rights and
fundamental values ​​even if our
governance models are different we
agreed that we should
try to cooperate on
artificial intelligence  at the
global level another
question resulted from the high-
level dialogue that we have therefore relaunched
since my last visit that and therefore
the solution sought was on
cross-border data flows as you
know European companies for a
very long time have expressed concern about this
matter and said he was worried about the fact
that there was no clarity in the
applicable rules and I am very
happy therefore that China is willing
to set up a mechanism
to clarify the rules this will be important
for European companies  and
now that we have heard this
commitment we hope to see it
quickly materialize in
practice we also discussed the
Chang climate and the fight against
climate change as you know COP 28 is
underway and I am delighted that China has
decided to join
the initiative to combat
methane emissions and it would be very
significant if China also committed
to
tripling the quantity of
renewable energy by 2030 and doubling
its energy efficiency also on
the horizon  2030 and therefore I can only
encourage China to make its
two commitments and already during the
first week of COP 28 135 countries
have joined this global commitment for
renewable energies it is a very
great success China is probably
the region  of the world where we have deployed the
most renewable energy it is a
very great success but
we have said it openly and
frankly at the same time we
are worried because what we are
seeing is  that we have more
coal factories in China than
previously we know the most
difficult in the fight against
climate change is the
gradual elimination of fossil fuels
this is obviously the discussion that is
underway in Dubai at the moment  right now at
COP 28 and of course we want
China to position itself very clearly to
progress in order to
gradually eliminate emissions by mid to
mid century
so eliminating
emissions the European Union and China
together have the  largest
certificate trading system in the world already in 2005
the European Union set up its
own
Côa trading system today 75
% of our carbon emissions have been the
subject of this
carbon pricing and we  we work closely
with the Chinese in order to explain what
should be done what
should be avoided what mistakes should not be
made and that is why
I am very happy because
we have renewed our protocol
The agreement for cooperation on the
coas trading system is a
system that is well known and has proven
to be profitable, to work
and to produce income which in
turn could be
reinvested in the  innovation and in
developing countries and therefore in
general climate change
this is an issue on which China
and the European Union can cooperate
in a very constructive way I
now turn to Ukraine the war
of aggression committed by Russia  is
a clear violation of
international law and the Charter of the
United Nations and it is a very
serious threat to the security of the
European continent, which is why
we reiterated that China
should use all its influence over
Russia to  put an end to this
conflict and to start working
on the basis of the 10-point peace plan
we called on China not to
provide lethal equipment to
Russia and also to help fight
against any efforts by Russia  to
circumvent the sanctions imposed on it
and finally we mentioned the
tensions in the region and in particular
in the
Taiwan Strait we have
increased tensions in the South China Sea which
risks undermining
regional security this is the reason  for which
we are completely opposed to
the status quo on Taiwan being modified
in particular by the use of force we
recognize the policy of one China
regional security will
also be strengthened if it is through the voice of
dialogue that we resolve the tensions and
differences around the Taiwan Strait,
to summarize you see it on the
table a lot of choices to be made
today we have an
open and sincere discussion and we have
agreed that for the n deviv The work
in the high
level di thank you thank you very much we
will start with the
FP
hello a question for
President
Michel for the fp the director general of the
department of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs indicated today that
Russia is an independent country and  that
President Putin was making his decisions
based on his own
security considerations given
such wording do you really think
that China will try to intervene and
that Chinese leaders will do
something to prevent
Chinese companies from circumventing
sanctions  today we are having a
very frank discussion about the conflict
and about the effect or rather the role of
China so we have made it very
clear that we are on the side of the
Ukrainian people and that we have put
in place sanctions and that
we  we want to convince all the countries of the
world, including China, not to
circumvent these sanctions, what is
important is also the
peace formula, as you know, China participated
in several
meetings at the level of
national advisors in charge of
security  to evoke this
peace formula it is a Ukrainian initiative and
it is obviously important to have
[Music]
the interest of the country that they do
not have evidence of they do not have
companies that
ccumventan
[Music]
andence  thank you
go
so for
Madam you mentioned pres and both of you
agreed the need to balance economic
relationship have you managed to discuss
how to rebalance for example Chinese pay
strong attention to this subs case from
eu have you reached any comm
understanding on this we know  next year
there will be the European
election if there are no progress made
in this economic
so we had an intense discussion on the
topic of trade imbalance and the ro
causes for the trade imbalance both with
President and the premier
and
of
an into specific
topics well  know and well
prepared and it was very good to change
fact and figures and we aged that we
have now a list of different elements
where
and of will determine the future of our
relationship that is important that we
have a Frank and open relationship and
that we have  stable trade relations with
each
other and therefore I think it's
important to see now the prog on the one
wasifation
disc of
medicinesp of
costics geographical indications there
we have 175 geographical indications
that we have been working on now that we
can now put into practice very concrete
and detailed steps but um this is the
way to address the
tradealances i would like add
that itolutely need convinc that
assessment will be needed in the to come
and we AG that important work fther
together and I also think that there are
today some concrete interesting
deliverables  in in field first we
decided to enlarge the list of the
geographical indication which is an
important topic also identified some we
try to more prog costs for inst Medes
equ
AGC arguments vision we are convinced this
question of the imbalances must be
addressed we to listen  to the arguments
of the chese side and we agree is
important now to more details to
identify what concrtion can can be
laun
nework Times did you get into a level of
detail specific Chinese companies that
may or may not be helping Russia avoid
sanctions and do you  feel that you made
enough progress regarding specific
companies that may be involved ins with
Russ that
you we have identified a list of
companies which are suspected to ro
SS and with opportunity to make clear
points in preparation of this summit but
alsoing the summit we agree  important to
go more into the into the details and we
sincerely hope that today we are h and
then the appropriate action will be
undertaken by
China we have also have also the
opportunity to debrief our m because the M
States will have to decide what action
can  be done
me this is a process that is oning
already before the summit so this is a
question of permanent dialogue what the
potential circumvenes of some it doesn't
have to be Chinese owned companies but
Chinese based
companies is concerned and here we
had
[Music  ]
igin
the
dayses
[Music]
neverifation
of
Blomberg foring BL i if we go back to
the
an and just a little bit more about that
did actually
come up and what was the Chinese respse
to that for example did they agree to
cooperate with investigation um  and what
was the response to your explicit
request on this issue and can you talk a
little bit about any other concerns that
might have been raised such as 5G for
example Chinese companies with 5G in
Europe and did you warn China that you
would launch new probes  and possibly
impose new measures going forward thank
you never friend of War I think it is
more effective that you speak to each
other and that on the basis of fact of
figures and facts of figures and
therefore what the EV investigation is
concerned as in any investigation  you
know no coms during the investigation
the investigation is
ongoing of course the topic was led
without any question
um [
Music]
of
con the lack of access to the Chinese
market the
overcacity that is f by a slowing
demand and the overcacity leads to
spover effects  ofob Marets
and Glob mar
produced to the European single market and
here was an intense discussion about how
to deal with that because we think that
it is in China's
interest to deal with the overcapacity and
China has the
toolsanc
c disc with auor subs Barri and capaties
and for each of those topics we went
into the detail ch arguments we why we
that for balancing our EC relationship
we need to add thoses and we agreed that
it is needed to go more into the details
and to see what can be done to
guarantee  more
take the last the Irish
IR when you Rais the ISS of Chinese
engagement with the
raanos with President what he say in
resp i think the responsibility
to the
first here about one year ago in
December and then other Europe leaders
came to beij to to  meet with the CH
authorities and on the EU side we speak
with one voice we are absolutely
convinced that it must be clear that
this war against Ukraine is a violation
of the international law violation of
the un charter and that's why we do not
give up and  we try to convince very
important to use all possible tool and to
use all possible influence to China
to stop and
there easy to have peace in Ukraine China
just to stop the war and to respect the
Bard internationally recognized of RA to
respect the integrity of
Ukraine this  ISEM important opinion that
China participate in the next mee for this
accredited by
ukra
and so indeed it is to President she to
define his own position um we have been
clear since the beginning of the war
that how China will
position vis the Russian AGR towards
ukra  this will define our relationship
eu China
import
r
ukraina thank youident W up the prerence
foring
[Music]